[Applause]
so when I move
back he comes in I bring my face with me
so I can move back
in don't move back foot only is now you
can't get back
in and you didn't really
leave so as he
goes and this strategy is something that
you you using your uh pugilistic so for
example um I'll have he's measuring me
and he'll measure off where my chest is
and my front foot and people get in the
assumption that my back foot is where it
is okay but you can start faking this by
bringing that back foot up so you do
different things like for example let's
say he throws some combination and I'm
kind of here right and instead of
putting that foot back there me do it
again right I moved it here and so now
when he goes back to his base I really
have a lot of range that I can come in
okay
so this is very much like a a fake I'm
not trying to go and get out of the way
like that I'm faking how much more I can
come back in
okay
home fake here and now now you can go
all that way stay there you can go all
that way
back face
out all the way back
in face
out all the way
back all the way back okay try that
nothing's as easy as it looks okay um so
when we're here he goes in and I goes
back I don't want my line of
gravity to move in the middle of my body
I don't want it to go like
that going boom
boom in okay CU we know if he gives me
pressure you see and I try to I can't
push that CU I'm not ground vect I'm
sort of falling into
okay
instead I have to ground the back foot
the foot will go out you see I
shift and then the foot comes
in so in this work nice and slow
one no you're not his he can keep
pressure on my weapon and actually keep
me out
okay I'll do the mistake again
one
two okay instead
slow one ground ground foot out boom
in
mistake correct boom ground foot slide
body comes in
mistake it's not it's yeah you probably
will focus on the Lurch step but the
problem is that my Center gravity goes
up under pressure right here is where it
gets caught I'll never get back down
okay the correct way ground
slide comes the back foot okay
boom okay try it
again okay
so I know I'm going to go
back right I know I'm going to go back
and then I know I'm going to go forward
and I know when I go forward I can't go
like that so I know I have to ground the
back foot so as I go back I ground and I
come in it's one one move
down so you can see it's
reversing this foot is going to ground
as I go back you see I drop I push back
I drop I push forward so there's a
circle here
Bo so instead of this straight back
straight P you see that
okay
absorb and then I'm picking up my timing
now right this is the embryonic timing
oh he stops and I I have to hit him in
the midst of him hit so that's where the
absorption
[Music]
you can start shrinking it and shrinking
it more okay just like in your body Ard
so walk in
way right is
absorb of
absorb by rounding the corners do you
understand by not zigzagging okay so the
same thing
here
andriana
application
okay
tror
side note on tension okay so
um when I'm
here it's just like a a standing
exercise everything drops I release
everything it drops and everything is
vectored onto the midfoot okay and just
because come in on me and I'm hiding
behind the sword you see everything is
the same the tip everything like that I
release and they'll Center the body on
midfoot okay so as he
goes right and I now I feel the tip of
his sword that gets ground Vector too
and gets released to okay and now I can
I can feel him so as he goes I can move
with okay but I have to be relaxed
so as I do the drill and I'm all relaxed
I just keep everything relaxed okay at
this level that's how I would like you
to
train okay so I start with me round
Vector everything he goes to Sega on
right and I'll feel that I ground Vector
his tip too he goes I absorb and I'm
relaxed relax
relax you see my shoulders are down in
the same stance I'm doing the same
exercise this this is tension
okay so it's just energetic right now
boom
po
relax everything
sinks my grip
is an i adhesion with the book in don't
don't squeeze it it just stuck to
it everything drops in that
instance
all right same goes for
UK usually the tension on the nget side
it's fear-based it comes from you you'll
feel unafraid or you'll feel better if
you overpower and cut him down it's
spear based so that desire spear based
okay and then on the side you usually
don't want pain so it's another kind of
Desire but it's also fear based okay so
when I'm the
UK I have
to to me like UK is like a death
meditation you have to be um come off
the wall you have to uh be ready to be
hit and like not freak out from it okay
uh when you touch the swords you have to
be ready to die so that you can and
release in the face of the pain that's
going to probably trigger you okay and
the the weird part about the universe is
the more fear-based you are the more
you'll do things that actually generate
the pain that you're trying to dread and
not not have happen Okay so same thing
as I'm UK I do the same thing and as I
go in he goes and I'm going to be loose
okay he he will move me if I just keep
to that same energetics
okay I don't I don't have to go in and
then try to take to K me or he will move
me okay I not let him move
me attention
[Music]
relax
okay try to get rid of that tension on
both nog the desire to overpower and as
UK the desire to not be overpowered get
rid of it all okay stick to the
energetics all right let's go into the
yin and yangong aspects of this maneuver
okay so on the embryonic all embryonic
timing
are going to be exaggerations okay um so
for example he's going to get to F you
see he got to
Fong and I have to go to F Yen so I'm on
this side so if he pushes down it slides
up I'm not lifting up on his weapon
because he'd be pushing down on my
weapon you see and I'm not in that cross
there camera so you can see it where I'm
underneath 90 at the 90 underneath
because that's where his weight is I had
to rotate to the other side of it at a
minimum that 45 so that he finds that
angle okay do you understand okay but if
you pay
attention when you get to the
application if you do that he comes in
and you do that you now aren't doing
your attack in the midst of his attack
you have to wait so that's that doesn't
make sense that never works martially
your attack is in the midst of his
attack so as as he goes over it's
already been
Yin okay and so now what I do is this
angle is different than he had before
and so now I can come straight in and
hit it so
embryonically yes yes architecturally it
looks like
this but
energetically y to
Yin okay is the opening so here you go y
to Yin and it's there and so the
difference is you stop functioning as a
practitioner architecturally and you
start functionally energetically as soon
as you feel his Yin you're going to come
down it you have your Yin opening for Ed
okay so uh I don't want you to start
doing a different technique you see I
pushed against you okay there is a
slight yield boom and then in it's just
smaller and the same way don't go here
that's now you have the unmarshal timing
okay there is a slide W yield an in and
it's it is energ ically the same opening
just not exaggerated
walk you can see how I'm not really
pushing on his sword it's just there the
the opening is
there so move and just falls into that
place I just follow it okay so uh let's
do that let's let's understand at the
application Level I'm more obeying the
energetics and not the architectural
design of the embryonic form okay all
right try it
again in the move there's an touching
okay so we go and we come back boom it's
right there okay uh you always have if
you're going to thrust someone you have
to stabilize the target so that it adds
resistance to the piercing as opposed to
he's up and let's say he's stumbling
backwards then there's not going to be
the penetration okay so you always have
to check him out before you you hit him
it's the same thing like if we're here
and uh he's moving backwards and I clock
him that punch is not going to do what I
need it to do okay you have to find some
way some way of and now that punch will
do what I wanted it to do
okay so the
atos we're we're going to talk about it
for a little bit everything's the same
he goes I Rel release and my weight is
is on there is on the tip okay so I'm
not really holding holding this thing
you can see I'm not driving it down but
he should not uh be able to pick that up
you see he should feel my base my base
in in what I'm doing you see my base is
over there it's no different than if he
tries to lift my hand you see no he
should feel go you feel you feel my base
you see my base is in there it's not
that I need my elbow or anything like
that it's the same thing when it comes
time to throw he he should feel the
weight of my base
boom in my hand okay it's no
different than the skill of putting
weight away from my body
okay so a one Bo and he'll feel the
weight
feel the
weight okay feel the weight it's not
it's not that I'm doing that you don't
want to bring tension back in your body
so we'll go a little wi
okay
that one's a little light
huh okay so I got to get my weight on
the end and I have to attack the center
okay
um let's try here we
go okay so uh what you doing in this
form
energetically is one side of your body
on the uh spiral cross rotation okay um
so for example if I was just here
statically OB it is the boat rowing
exercise okay um is what you're doing in
the in the form but what in essence what
I'm doing is I'm standing releasing I'm
going to shift weight to a single Vector
on the back going make that heavy
it'll come back forward around and then
make the other the front foot heavy okay
so let's see I don't know if this will
work maybe the camera can be over there
and then he's over here okay and so as
they're they're both pushing on me okay
and I ground the back
foot and he he can try to lift it and
you can feel my weight is on it do you
see okay and then as I come forward
they're both pushing still and as I come
forward I have to move you'll see Roden
moved you see and then the weight drops
on the front foot and he tries to lift
it and I'm just here and they're trying
to lift it and I'm just doing the
standing meditation okay again don't get
confused with the shape the shape does
the shape doesn't matter they can't lift
it from there either they they're trying
to lift my whole body it does it doesn't
matter okay so again
boom drop Shifting the weight
boom back foot you feel the weight
Shifting the weight to the front Vector
boom dropping the weight on the front
Vector okay and this is what I'm doing
so my my chi flow is in many ways like
gravitationally influenced by my center
of gravity okay and so as I'm moving my
body around my chi and my mind will
follow this pattern with my weight and
this is the concentric tie between the
physical and the energetic okay so as
we're going here we just now have more
gross movements but I have to feel the
same thing inside my toen so yes I have
to take a step but weight will shift
shift right and the chi will drop do you
understand the chi will drop who it'll
compress I'll come back forward boom and
the chi will drop again do you guys get
it and you're you're basically doing the
boat exercise which is the spiral
rotating of the lower tonden field on
one side of the body okay you're
basically doing that so that would make
this wrong do you guys see that I'm just
I'm just up here my
energy and my mind must sink sink sink
okay and I can make that smaller and
Tighter h
okay let's try it so um if we look at
Keon was you kind of have an energy CU
which in this case would be the the
initial ski okay it would be that and
then you're going to have your Yin yield
catch right you're going to follow your
energetic rules and uh boom that
technique is done that that's a killing
blow you see that so that that's the end
of the technique uh in Chima sets you
have these counters do you get it and so
it's a good thing I this is why we do it
and I want you to understand it um it
helps you understand uh how to find the
yin space the absorption and contact
from different starting angles than like
seon or something which is like a
classic starting angle just like
katatori is a classic starting angle
okay versus is like sometimes we do
techniques from the clinch right or
sometimes we do handcut wasall and he
can counter and do all all kinds of
things and then you have to find your uh
iido elements from that starting point
not the classic uh entry Cube okay uh so
this set continues and so for example uh
he goes I'm doing my thing he's going to
yield and come around and we'll keep
that other foot forward
cuz it's going to be fast okay so he
goes W he's going to do it now to me and
you can feel that you lifted my sword
little okay he has the same Yin yield
energetics so boom boom better you want
my tip to fall into empty space boom no
switch rolls okay I'll show you the two
two uh errors okay so one
right we do
sorry one you feel it there's lifting
there okay you you'd actually overpower
that thing and then the other one is
that uh one and you come off okay again
I'm going to let you move so move he
moves my
sword one he moves my sword very much
just like this one he moved my sword you
see you move my
sword I let your move my sword so
one again if I'm doing this right I
don't need any tension in my
body never
lifting nor shaping his sword so between
the three this is what why I can let go
there's three points of control if
you're you're controlling that right do
you understand what I mean like I can
balance it on you and so I can move
around as I'm doing all that as I come
off your sword I got to grab my weapon
okay
boom boom boom
boom
and then let's look at the footwork
again so one see he comes in I move and
move with
you
one just the
footwork
got me
huh okay let's try all right let's look
at the lines again so uh I'm coming
in okay he's going to come straight in
ski
in okay got it all right and then we
know
at the end I'm cutting from the
angle so here were my
hips oh I'm going to use this bulk in to
show you the my hip angle okay this is
the hip angle of H
me if I just step over to the
side I don't I'm not oriented towards
him do you see that so at some
point these hips had to root
rotate and get that Hy angle to him
okay so not just stepping to the side
okay so I go I'm not going like this cuz
I would miss you see it's some point
there's some
rotation so we're going to go
slow that rotation should be
here you see because that's your yield
is there against his
energy so one and you yield to his
energy you see how I'm turning and that
is you do that all the time in in your
art all the time
okay you're
even right here you see the qua the qua
yielding okay so the same thing here
you're going to and and this is what
allows you to keep the spiral
rotation of the lower Tom Den so as I go
inom totally not it
and as I'm rotating you're going to see
that you have to drop boom because my
feet separated you see so my
feet are going to
drop shift weight
draw not it you guys see that difference
Okay so
so we okay so now as he goes and you
follow the
rule
foot knee
qua elbow you see that is where your
kitty happen so you got to go really
slow no much slower than that okay so
he's going we go you see how it's
staying with the quaw okay he goes Bo
yield
boom
W boom
boom if I do that I'll never end up on
the other side of my body the camera
come over here this is very common your
kitty guys just the elbow came broke the
qu R and then you have this head over
there keep your elbow with your
CLW boom
around boom boom
boom
never
here there'll be too much y on the on my
sword and he'll be able to push it down
that's when it hit you in the body
okay W free it
elbow
quw
stuck okay try
it
okay so going back back again to the
energetics uh when he push I yield and
when I push he
yields
okay you push I yield he P I push he
yields okay and so in essence we're
following the yin space so there's the
yin space in there's the yin space out
okay so I'm going to follow that same
space pull right into
him in the same
way that I don't lose
connection and he doesn't lose
connection I don't want to lose
connection
here Stu
Stu there's no
Gap the in space best I
felt so if you look at our timing I just
have one
Counterattack okay he
goes and that's what I'd like you to
do as opposed to your taking
turns I out of space I have one
aggressive
o one counter
squ
counter okay let's
try
e
you see how my V is not sliding
okay I'm going to generate an adhesion
there okay what what would what do it
look like if I don't
so we know for the adhesion I got to
match in my discourse I got to match the
Yang value okay it's the Yang value of
his his energy his inertial momentum
going forward on his cut and then the
gravitational uh energy of his Mass I
had to match that so my book and sticks
so that I can cook you
okay so it's not that I'm just there and
I'm I have my lightsaber
and I'm going to cut his arm okay you're
getting you're you're taking his balance
because you're in grappling range you
guys see that okay so you're going to
disturb his base B pop and so it has to
stick
okay
no
that's the S
[Music]
okay then as you
projecting now you you have resistance
towards your
cut
okay let him breathe
out
[Applause]
try
he so in some fencing schools uh
you'll have like a they'll call this
like oh it's kind of stalemate he
doesn't want me to cut his neck I don't
want him to cut my neck okay um these
are called binds in some
schools
um an empty
hand they're called
clenches do you understand so we're
we're here he's trying to push he
doesn't want me to punch him or need him
and so you're kind of checking all that
kind of stuff do do you understand
that's a bind
okay and when you get in binds as we
have many techniques you try to disturb
someone's base you have to otherwise
it's just a matter of time before they
do it to you okay so uh it's very
rare I would say there's no point in
binding if we're just going to stand
here in place you see there's always a
pressure do you feel that you see
there's with some pressure where you're
trying to uh disturb his balance okay so
on this one we know where shaku is right
stay there
please sheu is right
here so as as we're he's driving in me
I'm driving into the shikaku do you see
and now it creates just enough of a
different relationship that he wants to
push on me you see and then
you'll have your suit timy waza Etc you
get it as opposed to we're here is in
perfect balance and I try this technique
he's going to he's going to kill me
okay got it
okay so here you have a kind of
grappling binding maneuver I don't want
you to think of it as a lightsaber
okay as I go in pop you want that
okay that's that's your goal boom pull
this that's your goal get him out of
there I'm not
here got it I'm running at him
get in here boom out of the grappling R
and when that energy going
back he's going back that's when I take
that cut and now I just let again this
is another Marshall concept you get any
kind of potentially lethal blow you
should
disengage and see what's going to happen
Okay so let's say we're sparring and
boom and I feel that knee just go CRA
okay you could come back in but you're
probably safer on letting that thing
faster same thing in law
enforcement Bo boom all right get to
cover and assess instead sitting there
Stand Down the open and trying to have a
g fight with some okay same kind of
concept
here so boom and pop boom and then
out
different
[Applause]
okay okay let's try
for